we're told that in a population of pea
plants some plants have round seeds and
others have wrinkled seeds
the gene for seed shape in this
population has two possible alleles
remember alleles are just versions of
the gene
one allele or one version is for round
seeds which we're denoting capital r and
the other allele is for wrinkled seeds
which we're denoting lowercase are and
they're telling us that the round seed
allele the capital r is dominant
for a cross between two pea plants that
are heterozygous for the seed shape gene
determine the expected ratio of
offspring with round seeds to offspring
with wrinkled seeds
all right like always pause this video
and see if you can have a go at this by
yourself before we do this together
all right now let's think about the
genotype for the two pea plants that are
heterozygous
heterozygous means they have two
different versions of the gene or two
different alleles so these are going to
be two pea plants that are capital r
lowercase r they have one of each
and to see what happens in a cross
between them i will draw a punnett
square
so
just like this
and i will explain what i am doing in a
second here
so i'll draw it like this
so what you need to think about is you
have your two parents
and so
each parent is capital r lowercase r
now that means that let's say parent one
can contribute the capital r to the
offspring or it could contribute the
lower case r allele to the offspring and
the same thing could happen for the
other parent it could contribute the
capital r or it could contribute the
lower case r so what are all of the
equally likely possibilities for the
offspring
well the offspring might get a capital
the dominant allele the round seed
allele from both parents capital r
capital r all i'm doing is i'm taking
whatever letters in the column and
whatever's in the row
it could get a
capital r from this parent
and a lowercase r from that parent it
could get a lowercase r from this parent
and a capital r from that parent
or in this situation it's getting a
lower case r from either one
so these are the four equally likely
genotypes now they're not asking us
about genotypes they're saying determine
the expected ratio of offspring with
round seeds to offspring with wrinkled
seeds
so what does the genotype have to look
like in order to have round seeds
remember the round seed allele is
dominant well this would be a situation
where you could be capital r capital r
but it's dominant so you could also be
capital r lowercase r and still have
round seeds the only way that you're
going to have wrinkled seeds right over
here is if you are homozygous for the
wrinkled seed allele so this is the only
wrinkled seed scenario so if you look
here you look see out of the four
equally likely scenarios three of them
end up with a phenotype of round seeds
and only one of them ends up with a
phenotype remember phenotype is what's
being expressed only one of these four
equally likely scenarios has a phenotype
of wrinkled seeds so the expected ratio
is going to be you're going to expect to
see three
offspring with round seeds for every one
with wrinkled seeds or you would expect
a
three
two
one ratio
now i have another part of this question
that is asking us
what about a cross between a pea plant
that is homozygous for wrinkled seeds
and one that is heterozygous pause the
video again and see if you can have a go
at this one
all right so the first thing that i like
to do is just think about what are going
to be the genotypes for each of these
parents
so if we're talking about homozygous
for wrinkled seeds remember the wrinkle
t allele we're denoting with the
lowercase r so that's going to have a
genotype of lowercase r lowercase r
and then they say one that is
heterozygous
well we already saw that before that's
going to be capital r and lowercase r so
let's draw a punnett square again
to be able to do this
so
i'll do it like this
like
that
like that and then make sure i have two
columns and two rows
and let's put the homozygous parent up
here they could either contribute a
lowercase r
or they could contribute a lowercase r
they're going to contribute one of these
two and then let's think about the
heterogeigus parent
well they can contribute a capital r the
dominant allele or they could contribute
a lower case r so let's think about the
equally likely scenarios here at least
for genotype
well these these are all scenarios in
which we get a capital r from this
parent over here the heterozygous parent
i guess i could say so let me write
capital r
capital r
and in both of these scenarios we're
getting the lowercase r from the
homozygous parent
and both of these situations are we are
getting the
wrinkled seed allele from both parents
you're getting the lowercase r
from the heterozygous parent and in
either scenario you're getting a
lowercase r from the homozygous parent
so let me write that right over here
so which of these genotypes would have a
phenotype of round seeds
well round seeds
is going are going to be scenarios where
you have at least one of the round seed
alleles so these are all going to be
round seeds right over here they're
going to have a phenotype i should say
of round seeds because remember the
round allele is dominant even though you
have one of each
the dominant allele is what you're
actually going to see in the phenotype
here
and then
we see these two are going to be
wrinkled
wrinkled
so what's the ratio of round to wrinkled
going to be well it's going to be one to
one for every two round you're going to
have two wrinkled or for every one round
you're going to have
one wrinkled two to two is the same
thing as one to one when we're talking
about ratios and we're done